bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
débat sur france 24 22e jour de guerre
en ukraine et on cherche toujours à
établir le bilan du bombardement russe
sur un théâtre de mario pouliot
s'étaient réfugiés des centaines
d'habitants plus d'un millier même de
personnes se trouvaient dans le théâtre
selon le maire de ce port stratégique
d'ukraine la russie a affirmé ne pas
avoir bombardé la ville à washington joe
biden a accusé son homologue russe
vladimir poutine d'être un criminel de
guerre volodymyr élèves qui enchaîne les
appels à l'aide aux occidentaux devant
le bundestag aujourd'hui où il a été
ovationné le président ukrainien avait
accusé l'aviation russe d'avoir
sciemment bombardé le théâtre de
marioupol alors poutine est il un
criminel de guerre comment justifie t-il
cette guerre auprès de sa population
le président russe devra t-il rendre des
comptes on va en parler avec mes invités
j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés le
général dominique dolor bonsoir à vous
et bienvenue dans le débat ancien chef
du centre opérationnel interarmées à
côté de vous rony brauman bonsoir
directeur d'études à la fondation msf
plus exactement au sein de crash centre
de réflexion sur l'action et les savoirs
humanitaire vous êtes également médecin
et ancien président de msf nous avons
avec nous en duplex de la et élise le
gal bonsoir à vous et bienvenus avocate
au barreau de paris histoire près de la
cpi la cour pénale internationale
bienvenue également dans le débat nous
irons bien sûr albi il veut retrouver
gulliver craag notre envoyé spécial et
puis elena volochine se joindra à nous
dans 5 minutes à peu près notre
correspondante france 24 en russie
gulliver on va tout de suite vous voir
en ukraine donc à lviv marioupol kharkov
thermique gif on peut dire que les
populations civiles sont de plus en plus
visés dans ce conflit
oui on peut rajouter lobby genest
severodonetsk où les villes plus près de
ce qui était la ligne de front dans le
dôme basse pendant huit années il est
difficile vraiment de continuer à
enregistrer toutes les informations qui
nous parviennent tous les jours sur des
endroits dans différentes parties de
l'ukraine
des cibles ont perdu des civils ont
perdu la vie qui ont été ciblés par
l'artillerie russe je pense que chaque
cas individuel devrait être l'objet
d'une enquête si éventuellement il y
aura un tribunal pour crime de guerre
mais dans l'ensemble il paraît
absolument évidente que la russie est en
train de cibler les civils et
délibérément le bombardement
indiscriminé du centre-ville de
marioupol et des archives et le montrer
clairement qu' il y a une volonté je
pense que faire en sorte que les civils
souffrent le but étant clairement de
faire peur aux civils de faire en sorte
que peut-être c'est ce que les russes
apparemment espèrent les civils vont
décider qu'il vaudrait mieux vivre même
sous la russie plutôt que de résister
que les habitants deux autres villes
vont adopter une attitude un peu moins
des fientes que celle adoptée par les
citoyens de la majorité des endroits où
l'ukraine qui ont été ciblés on le voit
ici les déplacés qui viennent à lviv qui
ont fui le conflit ils sont toujours
dans cette position de défiance ils
disent que l'ukraine doit continuer à
résister à la russie donc malgré le fait
qu'il n'y a pas vraiment une évidence
que cette stratégie de cibler les civils
porter des fruits absolument au
contraire cela ne fait qu'augmenter la
colère et la haine contre les russes il
est clair que c'est la stratégie que la
russie est en train d'adopter d'utiliser
d'employés en ce moment merci gulliver
gulliver cloud donc en direct de lviv en
ukraine rony brauman l'armée russe qui
impose un siège hermétique à marioupol
depuis 16 jours il faut le redire une
maternité un théâtre plus de 2000
personnes ont été tuées à marioupol
selon les ukrainiens on ne sait pas très
bien comment il va lui le nombre de
civils quels sont vos informations à ce
que vous en avez en particulier rony
brauman en fait on a peur sur mario paul
pas beaucoup plus d'informations que
seuls dont vous disposez celle dont
auxquelles on a accès par la presse car
nous sommes totalement coupée de nos
équipes ou ex équipe à marioupol
médecins sans frontières avait une
équipe qui étaient postés là bas depuis
2014 mais qui s'occupait de maladies
chroniques de centres pour enfants de
maladie de tuberculose résistante de
questions de santé publique
et une équipe d'ailleurs essentiellement
ukrainien nommé soutenu par des équipes
de médecins sans frontières disons
d'europe de l'ouest mais là nous sommes
vraiment coupé donc la seule chose que
nous avons réussi à confirmer c'est que
c'était un désastre que la population
était littéralement à étrangler qui
avait plu plus d'électricité plus
d'énergie donc un froid glacial les
difficultés d'alimentation d'accès à
l'eau d'accès aux soins bref une
situation totalement catastrophique mais
malheureusement je n'en sais pas plus
que cela et par exemple pour ce qui
concerne le bilan de cette attaque
contre le théâtre nous n'avons pas plus
d'informations est-ce que vous retrouvez
tout de même c'est objectifs de guerre
qui sont ceux justement de terroriser la
population
avec ce qui se passe à marioupol ces
villes qui sont assiégés oui mais ça se
ressentira travail et l'otan en syrie
auparavant en tchétchénie pendant ces
guerres et on retrouve une sorte de
ligne continue toutefois je pense que au
stade où on en est en tout cas je ne
préjuge pas de l'avenir nos stades où on
en est il faut tout de même différencier
la manière les méthodes de guerre
utilisant d'ukraine de celles qui
étaient utilisés en syrie en syrie le
l'armée russe est totalement alignée sur
l'armée syrienne sur l'armée de bachar
el-assad est le mot d'ordre c'était
aucun quartier on c'est à dire on
bombardait de façon intense avec toutes
sortes de projectiles toutes sortes de
munitions des quartiers civils le siège
d'alep atenor celui des hommes cela est
également celui de jaca bref il ya eu
une série de massacres littéralement et
d'ailleurs les bilans ont été très
rapidement extrêmement élevé donc on
n'en est pas là là il me semble que
mario paul ne représente pas l'ensemble
de l'ukraine mais plutôt une situation
et il faut espérer que ce sera pas le
cas plus tard c'est à dire que le
maillot paul ne va pas s'étendre à tout
d'ukraine mais il me semble à ce stade
en tout cas qu'il ya un peu plus de
retenue
sans doute pas du fait de préoccupations
d'ordre humanitaire de la part du régime
russe mais du fait qu'il y a tout de
même une attention médiatique une
pression politique diplomatique beaucoup
plus forte que celle qui prévalait en
syrie donc les conditions de lumière sur
les conditions disons extra militaires
ne sont pas exactement les mêmes
en ukraine alors espérons que le combat
le la guerre va être un petit peu moins
meurtrière que celle que l'on a vue en
syrie d'enfin pour l'instant la
situation est vraiment très grave un
général 2002 lors le bilan des victimes
civiles on voit qu il s'alourdit avec
les bombardements alors que l'armée
russe elle subit de nombreuses pertes
sur le terrain quelle est la stratégie
militaire russe alors je crois que il
faut bien observer qu'il ya beaucoup
plus de villes et villages que le siècle
dernier est due au développement
démographique industriel mode d'habitat
et c est que les zones urbanisées
deviennent des zones de combat hors des
zones de combat parce qu'elles peuvent
intéresser celui qui attaque en
l'occurrence et russes parce que s'il ya
des nôtres outre les objectifs
politiques il ya des ponts il ya des
voies ferrées et à des grands carrefours
il ya des ports en l'occurrence et puis
pour ceux qui on a résisté
et notamment résister à des forces
blindées des villes sont des zones où on
peut beaucoup plus facilement organiser
une défense anti char donc c'est ce qui
se passe on s'installe on utilise des
mets des missiles et effectivement ça
devienne une zone de combat zone de
combat avec toutes les horreurs qui vont
derrière je n'avais pas prévu les russes
alors enfin part je pense qu'il ya une
telle règle voulait yahia je pense dans
les teams civile celle qui relève du
crime de guerre c'est à dire des actions
délibérées quand été menées contre des
civils c'est un crime de guerre et puis
il ya tous les dommages collatéraux dus
à l'imbrication entre combattants et
craignant les populations civiles face à
des des troupes russes donc on a
effectivement de la une alors la
stratégie de manière générale elle est
il ya des dépenses justement face à une
telle résistance alors
et les armes et classique aime pas les
combats dans les villes pour multiples
raisons parce que ça cesse et très
consommatrice en troupes et il en faut
beaucoup et en plus on se retrouve avec
tout ce problème de l'imbrication entre
combattants et civils manière générale
c'est pâques ce que recherche le soldat
ou même l'officier dans les conflits par
contre il peut y être obligé par son
pouvoir politique de prendre la ville
alors là on retourne dans l'art les
grandes problématiques des sièges comme
il y en a eu des siècles précédents
c'est à dire qu'on met la pression et la
ville à un choix soit se rendre
soit ce que ce soit continuer à
combattre donc là il continue à
combattre en gohelle on va écouter joe
biden le président américain qui lui a
accusé vladimir poutine justement de
d'être un criminel de guerre on les
écoute
non
[Musique]
reggae zouk
et anthony blinken qui hantera
d'ailleurs de de parler affirme
justement que viser des civils est un
crime de guerre il le redit donc le chef
de la diplomatie américaine on va tout
de suite à la et retrouver élise le gal
et liste de galles bonsoir à nouveau la
cour pénale internationale a ouvert une
enquête sur de possibles crimes de
guerre et crimes contre l'humanité en
ukraine l'annoncent pour l'instant ne
porte pas que sur les faits qui se
déroulent en ce moment mais me
semble-t-il l'enquète concerne tous les
actes commis par les russes en ukraine
depuis 2013 c'est cela
tout à fait cette enquête qui a été
ouverte par le procureur concerne tous
les actes qui ont été accomplis en
ukraine depuis 2014 donc c'est à dire
aussi depuis les exactions qui était qui
ont été commises lors de l'annexion de
la crimée est également donc toutes les
exactions qui sont en train d'être en
cours sur le territoire ukrainien et
cette enquête elle vise également donc
des actes qui sont susceptible de
recouvrir la qualification de crimes de
guerre mais c'est aussi ouvert à la
possibilité d'actes qui peuvent
recouvrer la qualification de crime
contre l'humanité donc effectivement le
procureur de la cour pénale
internationale qui s'est d'ailleurs
rendue il y a quelques jours sur place à
qui a rencontré les autorités
ukrainiennes montre à quel point
également il y à une pression judiciaire
qui est en train d'être mené concernant
la situation en ukraine et neurologie
nous avait rejoints bonsoir cette guerre
bien sûr c'est une gare aussi de
l'information l'a beaucoup dit la russie
a affirmé ne pas avoir bombardé la ville
de marioupol moscou accuse même d'après
ce que j'ai lu le bataillon
nationalistes ukrainiens azoff d'avoir
détruit l'immeuble
c'est encore une fois cette propagande
lna les russes se croit ces fausses
informations
oui alors l'épouvantail azoff c'est
effectivement un bataillon ukrainiens
qu'ils portent sans doute l'idéologie
néo-nazie mais qui est largement
minoritaire parmi si vous les forces
combattantes ukrainienne mais à chaque
fois que il y a crimes commis en ukraine
s'est toujours mis sur le dos du
bataillon aux offres on l'a eu aussi le
9 mars lorsque la maternité de marioupol
a été bombardé et la russie ayant dit
que c'était une base du bataille en
azote cette fois on a eu le bombardement
contre contre le théâtre alors là la
version est encore plus fort celle qui
est donnée par le ministère de la
défense russe parce que le ministère de
la défense russe nous dit c'est le
bataillon azoff qui a miné ce théâtre
qui retenait les eaux les civils en
otage à l'intérieur et donc c'est
lui-même qui a fait exploser ce cette
fameuse ce fameux théâtre et les russes
y croit parce qu'on leur marais c'est
une grande question sachez fois est ce
que les russes croient ou est ce que les
russes ne crois pas comment voulez vous
sonder l'opinion publique dans un pays
où tout est absolument verrouillé ou des
millions de gens dont j'ai lu qu'il y
avait des différences de générations par
exemple effectivement que les plus
jeunes n'étaient peut-être moi c'est à
dire que ceux qui n'y croient pas ils
ont sans doute peur de dire qu'il peint
qu'il n'y crois pas c'est toujours le
même problème et puis dernièrement c'est
devenu encore plus compliquée avec avec
avec ses discussions avec les russes
parce que les russes ont peur ils ça ils
savent qu'elle répression ils encourent
s'ils disent leur opinion s'est dit ce
que ce qu'il pense je pense qu'on va
encore une fois souligné qu' il y à de
très nombreux russes sans doute des
millions de russes qui croit fermement à
cette à cette histoire de nazis
ukrainien que la russie est à les
repousser sinon ils allaient attaquer
moscou et comme les gens allaient vivre
dans des caves jusqu'à moscou sous les
bons grecs torino film d'amiens bad ya
quelques mois on n'est pas du tout on
l'a entendu moi j'ai pas je parlais je
parle encore avec des gens qui me disent
vraiment texto si on n'était pas allé
bombardé l'ukraine les nazis ukrainiens
seraient en train de nous bombarder
enfin je le dirai on est dans une
réalité complètement parallèle dans une
dans une histoire qui a été réécrite de
ce côté ci du monde et en russie il
martelait chaque jour être isolé chaque
jour mais c'est une c'est une propagande
qui est continu qui haineuse qui est
vous avez entendu le discours de
vladimir poutine le chef de cette
propagande hier qu'ils nous disaient
qu'est ce qu'ils nous disaient ils nous
disaient que les russes saurait
reconnaître les traîtres et qu'ils
allaient les recracher comme on aurait
avalé une mouche et concombres
cracherait sur le pavé et que la société
russe devait être épurée de ces traîtres
enfin je veux dire quand vous êtes dans
un discours comme ça qui relève de 39-40
que comment voulez vous que les gens
soient niçois n'y crois pas soit soit ne
soit pas terrorisé à l'idée de dire
qu'ils n'y croient pas bon on va écouter
tout de même la journaliste russe marina
official nico va qui manifestement elle
n'y croit pas et cette journaliste qui
avait brandi l'écriteau nuwa je vous le
rappelle elle avait été arrêtée puis
relâchée elle était l'invité de marc
perelman cet après midi on écoute
j'ai pris la décision de faire ce geste
est
fort
pour dire que les rues sont contre la
guerre
d'autres disent pratiquer si d'autres
idées pour dire
se fier à la propagande et côté ce qu'on
dit de la télévision lui de la
télévision je suis déçu surtout
qu'il faut
faire cette distinction entre le
mensonge et la vérité oui nos médias
alors dit qu'il est patriote elle va
rester en russie elles risquent gros
bien sûr moi j'ai d'abord je suis je
suis assez inquiète pour cette dame
parce qu'une enquête a déjà été ouverte
en vertu de la nouvelle loi qui lui fait
encourir 15 ans de prison pour juste
pour avoir mentionné le mot guerre et
dire qu'il fallait que le qu'une guerre
c'était mal mais on a quelques
défections comme ça un parent ami on and
on a des informations parmi les dd de
défections parmi les structures parmi
les chaînes de télévision parmi les
médias des ballerines d'escaladé
exactement des artistes des responsables
d'entreprises etc voilà donc c'est on ne
peut pas jauger de que pense la société
russe dans une situation où d'abord elle
n'a pas la liberté de penser par elle
même et ensuite elle n'a pas le droit de
dire si jamais le prenez cette liberté
de penser alors bien sûr lorsqu'on parle
de crimes de guerre meilleure poutine a
déjà réagi me semble-t-il sur ce terme
en disant que c'est pas lui bien sure
you win mais ça c'est toujours
effectivement et d'ailleurs depuis le
début pardon depuis le début de ce
conflit de cette guerre il accuse les
ukrainiens de prendre les civils comme
boucliers humains de préparer les
américains de préparer des armes
biologiques sur le territoire ukrainien
les ukrainiens de y compris de crimes de
guerre alors c'est sûr mais attendez moi
j'ai entendu des gens j'ai entendu des
choses extraordinaires à la télévision
russe la voulait on les entend pas en
france mais des camps de concentration
des chambres de torture ça c'est des
choses qu'on entend au quotidien sur la
chaîne d'informations en continu
rossiya-24 notamment et dans l'émission
hebdomadaire d'un certain dimitri qui
c'est l'offre qui s'appelle et les
informations de la semaine on ne les
relève même plus quand on est comme moi
et qu'on regarde le journal télévisé
russe parce qu'on d'abord on y est prête
aucun crédit et ensuite c'est tellement
quotidien permanent et continu que ça
nous semble banal c'est vrai que quand
je vous le dis là comme ça vous me dites
ah bon ils ont parlé de lerus de comptes
concentration mais oui il en parle tous
les jours et ce depuis 2014 rony brauman
ans les pays occidentaux les ong
construisent un dossier tout de même
justement pour traduire la russie devant
la cour pénale internationale j'ai vu
que les ong d'ailleurs était très
impliqué est ce que est ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire un tout petit peu
plus là dessus est effectivement elle
joue un rôle pour ne serait-ce que
récupérer rassembler des preuves oui
bien sûr les ong jouent un rôle
important dans la justice internationale
s'est d'ailleurs parfois un rôle qui
peut être à double tranchant parce que
d'autres ong qui ne jouent pas ce rôle
là par exemple des ong d'actions
humanitaires comme médecins sans
frontières dont le rôle n'est pas de
rassembler des preuves mais de soigner
des gens peuvent être confondues avec
celles qui ramasse les preuves et qui
font un travail extrêmement utile que je
ne met pas du tout en cause mais qui
apporte aux procureurs un certain nombre
d'éléments que celui ci aurait eu du mal
à rassembler donc oui en effet le joueur
joue un rôle je voudrais réagir aussi à
ce que ce qui vient d'être dit parce
qu'effectivement devant cette situation
de lyon de cette fascisation du discours
de poutine cette espèce de ce déluge de
propagande immonde on a tendance à
renvoyer tout cela dans une espèce
d'ailleurs
inaccessible or moi je me souviens était
il ya exactement 11 ans presque jour
pour jour la france entrait en guerre
contre la libye à partir de contre le
pays la libye à partir de d'éléments qui
avait été entièrement fabriqué une
fausse attaque de manifestants contre la
démettre difficile face aux attaques
pardon aériennes contre des manifestants
à tripoli il faut charniers fausse
colonne de chars d'ailleurs on voit ce
que c'est qu'une colonne de chars n'a dû
fait de celles qui avancent vers vers
kiev bref un certain nombre de
songes propagandistes qui ont construit
une sorte d' ennemi qui lui aussi était
assimilable à un nazi la figure du
dictateur idéal et on a attaqué et on a
semé une sorte de enfin un véritable
chaos je me rappelle aussi aux états
unis les armes de destruction massive et
garnira énorme mensonge et les
conséquences absolument désastreuse qui
s'en sont suivies à chaque fois la
population qu'elles soient françaises ou
américaines suivaient son gouvernement
il y avait une sorte de l'esprit de
loyauté de soutien en force et armés qui
étaient mobilisés avant que du fait que
quand même aux etats-unis comme en
france nous sommes dans des sociétés
ouvertes avec un pluralisme de presse
réel avec une expression démocratique
donc il ya moyen d'aller chercher des
informations ailleurs et 7 les effets de
cette propagande ne dure pas en tout cas
dur beaucoup moins dur et là on va voir
mais je voulais simplement rappelé là
pour montrer que c'est
comment dire la mobilisation d'une
société derrière un chef à partir de
mensonges avérés en tout cas avéré plus
tard en l'occurrence ce n'est pas
l'exclusivité ce n'est pas l'apanage des
russes nous avons connu cela il ya blanc
donc il faut garder un peu distant six
mois je trouve très différent peut-être
voilà je suis alors je suis d'accord
mais je pense qu'il faut quand même
dissocier les choses et je pense que
c'est quand même dangereux de mettre ces
deux choses là sur le même ordre parce
qu'en russie on est non seulement sur
une justification d'une opération qui
seraient mensongères et qui serait
présenté ponctuellement comme tel et qui
serait suivi par la population et
qu'ensuite finalement il ya une vérité
qui aurait été faite en au terme d'
enquête au terme de contre 2 contre
opinion qui aurait été exprimé au terme
du fait que simplement les gens puissent
entendre aussi la version venus de
l'extérieur on est dedans complètement
autre chose en russie on est dans une
réécriture pure et simple est tout
simplement à l'envers de l'histoire de
qui est l'agresseur et qui est l'agressé
dans un coin je comprends très bien que
j'assure
la comparaison a ses limites je ne veux
pas je ne veux pas la forcer mais je me
rappelle que lorsque je mettais en doute
ici par exemple ou ailleurs les
assertions les allégations qui était
porté en demandant où était les photos
des charniers où étaient les photos des
colonnes de chars jeu on passait
facilement pour un suppôt de kadhafi le
problème et je veux pas on parle de
l'ukraine je ne veux pas rapporter tout
ça à la divination répondait rapidement
non parce que ça c'est que ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui est aussi
très a utilisé par là par les russes
pour dire d'envoyer les occidentaux nous
accuse mais en fait c'est eux qui
montrent la fial d'anthrax de collines
powell le le bombardement sur l'aide à
la vie ça non mais je me suis dis pas
que c'était bien le truc c'est que la
rhétorique des russes est toujours de
justifier le mal par d'autres mots en
fête et ça c'est assez dangereux parce
que les opinions lui qui ne discerne pas
les choses auront tendance à dire ah oui
alors donc la dîmière poutine peut être
dit la vérité et ça c'est un petit peu
dangereux alors quand on parle de crimes
de guerre générale 2002 lors on parle de
quoi il ya cette convention de genève
sur la protection des populations est-ce
que l'ukraine l'a signée est-ce que la
russie l'a signée est-ce qu
effectivement une guerre à des règles et
guinée la population civile ça veut dire
crimes de guerre disons qu on appelle ça
les lois et coutumes de la guerre
ça remonte pas faire un coup sympa
débuté à il ya 50 ans mais oui un siècle
haye depuis 2000 on a commencé à séparer
les les combattants et non-combattants
déjà déjà avec uniforme puis après ça
s'est développé et on vient pour faire
court aux conventions de lait et de
genève qui je dirais c'est d'établir un
cadre pour toutes les nations sur la
manière de faire la guerre ce qu'on doit
faire pour la déclarer pour pouvoir
discuter les ambassadeurs des cessez le
feu les trêves et c'est le comportement
avec les civils donc on va y venir bien
sûr et bien justement lorsque on rompt
lorsqu'on ne respecte pas ces
conventions tout de même on risque de se
retrouver alors aller au tribunal on
risque de se retrouver dès lors qu'il ya
un crime d'ailleurs qui est un crime de
guerre parle pas du tout il faut aussi
il faut le prouver à leurs crimes de
guerre c'est l'action délibérée
je dis bien délibérées contre des civils
une boum perdu ou un obus de chars qui
tape dans un immeuble d'où est partie un
missile et qui tuent malheureusement des
civils ça va pas de considérer comme un
m de guerre sera évidemment
malheureusement un dommage collatéral
parce que il ya eu une action de feu à
partir de cet immeuble et le char
marioupol par exemple mais là en
l'occurrence sur l'exemple qui est
aujourd'hui
des images que j'ai vues le théâtre est
bien isolé et très clairement indiqué
qu'une seule arrière et deux en russie
une seule explosion une seule explosion
et pour avoir fait un peu de targeting
pour employer le terme lorsqu'on prépare
des missions on regarde aussi évidemment
où on va mettre les bombes lorsqu'il
s'agit pas de bombardements d'artillerie
et tel qu'il apparaît il est manifeste
que c'est bien ce théâtre qui a été visé
et donc comme ce théâtre abriter des
civils là on est d'un bien sûr une
action délibérée contre les civils alors
pour déclencher la terreur sans doute
vraisemblablement un le toujours un peu
mais c'est un crime de guerre crime de
guerre élise le gal est ce que poutine
devra rendre des comptes justement est
ce qu'on peut faire un parallèle avec
d'autres procédures par exemple on
regarde de bosnie
alors ça ça a coupé mais effectivement
l'admirent poutine mais pas seulement de
la dîmière poutine également l'ensemble
des responsables et les plus hauts
gradés militaires et civils pourront
avoir à rendre des comptes un jour
devant la cour pénale internationale
puisque le statut de rome qui régit donc
là la compétence de la cour pénale
internationale prévoit bien dans son
article 8 la compétence pour les crimes
de guerre et dans cet article 8 il y à
une série de crimes qui peuvent donc
recouvrir cette qualification et dont
justement le fait de lancer des attaques
de manière intentionnelle sur des
populations civiles qui ne participent
pas à aux conflits ou encore sur des
infrastructures
civiles qui
recueille un certain nombre de civils et
qu'ils n'ont pas un objectif et ne
remplissent pas un objectif militaire
proportionnée à l'attaqué opéré donc le
précédent par exemple auquel on peut
penser c'est bien sûr la serbie
la guerre en bosnie oui alors bien sûr
tout à fait les précédents alors en
bosnie en serbie la création d'une
juridiction spécialisée pour eux donc
étudier les crimes qui ont été commis à
ce moment là mais devant la cour pénale
internationale le parallèle que l'on
peut faire c'est également dans le fait
de délivrer des mandats d'arrêt à
l'encontre d'un président en exercice
qui ne jouit pas d'une immunité pour
voir sa responsabilité
individuelle engagé en effet ce n'est
pas une responsabilité étatique qui va
être recherchée devant la cour pénale
internationale
mais des responsabilités pénales
individuelles si bien sûr le travail d'
enquête et de poursuites du procureur et
de la chambre permettront d'aboutir à ce
qu'il y a suffisamment d'éléments
probants qui permettent de mettre en
cause la responsabilité pénale
individuelle de vladimir poutine mais
également de l'ensemble des autres
responsables civils et militaires qui
ont sont intervenus dans la chaîne de
commandement et c'est en cela que il est
aussi intéressant de noter que
c'est bien et c'est une situation assez
inédite puisque dans ce travail qui a
été relatée à l'instant par les ong de
récolte de la preuve il faut aussi
savoir que la saisine de la cour pénale
internationale peut être faite par le
propriétaire pour par le procureur
proprio motu mais également avec l'aide
des ong et que là ce qui est intéressant
c'est que depuis quelques semaines ce
sont 41 états dont la france qui ont
déférer la situation à la cour pénale
internationale ce qui permet alors de
passer outre l'autorisation de la
chambre préliminaire donc cette rapidité
choisi pour
étudier en tout cas maintenir une
pression également judiciaire sur la
manière dont les conflits et donc ce
conflit doit se déguiser
ce
passé par l'ensemble des parties au
conflit est absolument inédite et doit
être saluée et qui prouve que ce n'est
pas un conflit qui est regardé de loin
mais qui est bien scruter et en tout cas
pour lesquels il y à une mobilisation
commune et concertée sur cette situation
mais on aimerait parler de pression là
il ya aussi une pression judiciaire a
effectivement un peu exceptionnel c'est
ce que c'est ce que vient de dire
justement notre notre notre invité élise
le gal il a le président du cicr qui en
ce moment en peter maurer d'après ce que
j'ai lu dans le monde il est en ce
moment en ukraine et il dit il faut
rappeler aux russes et aux ukrainiens
leurs obligations vis-à-vis des doigts
de la guerre il le dit dans une
interview au monde il ya aussi un enjeu
diplomatique
nous ne ressentons pas beaucoup
d'intérêt pour relayer des messages
justement du cicr et défendre les
conventions de genève donc ça c'est un
problème en soi enfin le oui le
président du cicr est actée dans est
dans son rôle il est considéré le
gardien le ccrc comité international de
la croix rouge donc c'est un organisme
très particulier puisque d'un organisme
privé de droit suisse mais qui a une
fonction diplomatique reconnu et celle
d'être le gardien et le promoteur des
conventions de genève à ce titre peter
maurer est un diplomate de haut rang et
il a la possibilité comme ça a été le
cas dans l'histoire à plusieurs reprises
de proposer ses services en tant
qu'intermédiaire neutre entre les
parties empruntées intermédiaire
vraiment tout à fait n'ayant aucune
aucun intérêt ils ont d'un côté ou donc
il est tout à fait dans dans son rôle il
espère faire passer des messages pour
l'instant on est dans une phase
ascendante dans une phase où la pression
contre l'agression russe mons mais
l'agression russe elle même ne cesse de
ceux de se déployer donc il n'ya pas
lieu d'être étonné qu'ils n'arrivent pas
à se faire entendre mais enfin faut pas
préjuger de ce qui va se passer ensuite
peut-être que d'ici une semaine ou
quinze jours la situation sera
différente et qu'il arrivera à être cet
intermédiaire actif que l'on attend le
rôle qu'on attend de lui si la
diplomatie effectivement avançait elle
général dominique de l'or alors j'ai vu
que le dirigeant de la république russe
tchétchène de tchétchénie ramzan kadirov
a assuré qu'un millier de volontaires
tchétchène était en route pour aller
combattre en ukraine trois semaines
après le début de l'offensive
kadirov alors on le sait a été très
critiqué par les ong pour notamment
graves violations des droits humains qui
ont eu lieu en tchétchénie c'est un
fidèle de vladimir poutine
kadirov n'a pas été simplement critiqué
par le cng kadirov est un criminel de
marie minel de maths prédateurs
terrifiant donc donc ce n'est pas de
bonne augure ce que je veux dire pour
justement retourner à notre sujet sont
de l'avenir poutine criminels de guerre
comme on en voyait des gens bloquent
l'observation ils sont déjà en ukraine
l'observation de faire c'est que pour
amener les criminels de guerre devant la
cour il faut il faut qu'il soit perdant
a notamment mené les gagnants devant une
cour donc il faut qu'ils perdent d'abord
donc le combat n'est pas terminé c'est
simplement à chaque fois des criminels
de guerre de journée quelque quelconque
concours c'est parce qu'ils avaient
perdue a donc si vladimir poutine gagne
cette guerre il ne sera pas
c'est dur judiciaire juridique
elles n'auront pas d'effet dit jose here
elles n'ont pas d'effet peut-être lui
disparaît sans l'histoire ouais il
rétablir les choses mais je veux dire
que il faut quand même pour amener
devant devant les tribunaux il faut
qu'on amène généralement que les
perdants et les
lycées
oui bien sûr generali et bien sûr je
tout à fait merci effectivement je
rejoins le propos du général mais en
apportant cette nuance que le temps
judiciaire n'est pas le temps politique
ni le temps diplomatique et bien souvent
c'est le temps aussi qui permet
également de réussir à monter et
constituer des dossiers solides et dans
le cas de ce conflit en ukraine si
vladimir poutine un jour
arriver à être en fonction effectivement
du respect aussi du principe des
principes du droit au procès équitable à
être jugé ou non devant la cour pénale
internationale si il faut qu'il s'en
sorte vaincu quand bien même il s'en
sortirait vainqueur il n'est pas exclut
encore une fois que les plus hauts
responsables et plus haut gradé puisse
un jour tout de même parvenir à être
jugée devant la cour pénale ationale ou
tout simplement aussi à devoir rendre
des comptes devant des juridictions
nationales qui applique le principe de
la compétence universelle et qui les
rendent compétent pour juger les
exactions qui rentre sous les crimes
relevant du statut de rome et qui auront
donc aussi cette possibilité de réduire
les zones d'impunité et où un dirigeant
ou un responsable militaire qui se
serait réfugié dans un autre état suite
et à la fin de ce conflit pourrait se
voir et être susceptible de devoir un
jour en des contres devant une instance
judiciaire celle qu'ils ont pensé les
acteurs de des actes
criminels
donc les criminels de guerre par action
est également les décideurs sont aussi
responsables savent aussi bien du pilote
jusqu'au président russe sur
l'occurrence elena moi je me demandais
si on allait si on allait
particulièrement vite parce que on ne
sait pas comment stopper vladimir
poutine c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas
intervenir militairement
les sanctions ça ne marche pas et
clairement il l'a dit donc saisir la
justice internationale mais que faire
pour l'arrêter finalement est ce que
vous dites c'est effectivement combien
de temps cet instrument la prendrait
pour avoir pour avoir un effet pour un
pur pourrait parce que finalement si
c'est pas ça qui va le stopper puisque
comme vous dites il aura fallu d'abord
que sinon versal et trans à permettra de
rendre des comptes c'est ça en fait la
justice mais ça
non alors c'est une guerre en cours qui
va durer ou il y aura des milliers de
victimes et c'est pendant cette guerre
si j'ai bien compris qu'on rassemble des
preuves que effectivement le procureur
va surtout d'ajustement étudie un petit
peu la situation et rassembler en
l'occurrence des preuves à moins
peut-être justement sur kadirov lna le
fait effectivement vous dites ils sont
déjà là donc les tchétchènes ils sont
déjà arrivés en ukraine ils sont combien
enfin peut-être oui à la combi lié
d'amitié les tchétchènes c'est c'est
alors j'ai pas le chiffre exact en tête
mais c'est ça c'est je crois que c'est
de l'ordre de 1000 à 3000 mais c'est ce
sont ces combattants parce que un
tchétchène en ce moment sous kadirov son
honneur et c'est celui de combattre
c'est ce sont toutes ces images qu'on a
vu de ramzan kadirov avec ses bataillons
avec ses forces qu'ils rassemblent dans
des stades qui défilent etc et qui n'ont
peur de rien ce sont des guerriers c'est
un peuple guerrier est aujourd'hui en
tout cas ceux qui sont inféodés aux
qu'avait kadyrov puisque évidemment il
ya tous les tchétchènes qui vivent sous
le joug de kadirov et qui subissent ce
joug de khedira au fait qu'ils n'iront
pas faire la guerre pour lui mais il y a
c'est s'efforce de structure un
militaire un qui sont dans les
structures fédérales russes c'est à dire
ce sont des divisions des structures
fédérales russes mais qui sont
tchétchènes est donc là c'est vraiment
un monde à part c'est un gouvernement à
part c'est un état dans l'état la
tchétchénie et donc qui ont été envoyés
en ukraine et moi je regarde les vidéos
notamment sur les tchats télégramme de
cette chaîne qui combattent lyonnais
beaucoup ça semble beaucoup en boucle
sur la zone sociaux in an mais ces
images énormément ils sont extrêmement
organisés ils ont une communication
incroyable ils ont des drones east c'est
à dire ils sont partis en guerre mais il
se met en scène ils envoient des
messages à ramzan kadirov ramzan tu peux
être fier de nous regarde on est là on
vaincra il se met en scène en train de
défoncer un portail à coups de pied pour
rentrer chez de prétendus combattants
ukrainien où ils sortent ensuite des
médailles de combat ukrainienne et des
passeports ducret break qu'elle est à ce
qu'ils ont un rôle en particulier oui
oui ils ont le rôle de gagner cette
guerre je veux dire là les tchétchènes
on s'appuie beaucoup sur eux parce que
non seulement ils savent combattre en
plus ils n'ont pas peur de mourir ils
sont ultra motivés ils sont super bien
équipés ils sont très bien payés
contrairement aux combattants de l'armée
russe qui sont restés pendant des mois
dans des camps d'entraînement emploiera
la frontière où ils ont passé un hiver
super u 10 sont arrivés affamées
épuisées exténué là dedans les
tchétchènes eux ils arrivent ils sont
armés jusqu'aux dents ils sont préparés
ils sont ils sont taillés pour la guerre
ce sont vraiment des il faut le
comprendre et ils sont là pour rendre
honneur à leurs dirigeants à ramzan
kadyrov qui lui a prêté une allégeance
absolue à vladimir poutine est ramzan
kadyrov ça fait des années qu'ils nous
dit il faut aller tous les massacres et
les nazis ukrainien donc il était motivé
depuis très longtemps les tchétchènes
rony brauman peut-être rebondir là
dessus enfin c'est accablant non je ne
sais je j'apprends des choses en
écoutant et
poursuit que l'accablement mais
peut-être juste une brève réaction à ce
que vous disiez auparavant la justice ne
va évidemment pas arrêter la guerre on
n'attend pas ça d'elle elle avant
peut-être un peu plus coûteuses et donc
elles entrent dans le calcul des
intérêts et des coûts qui peuvent être
que que peuvent faire des leaders
politiques qui vont en guerre mais une
guerre ça se prévient ou bien ensuite ça
se juge on en ramasse les morceaux une
fois qu'elle est terminé et qu'il ya eu
un vainqueur et un vaincu d'ailleurs
tout le monde sera vaincu d'une certaine
manière dans cette série n 1 il est peu
probable que la russie en tirent un
bénéfice important au contraire elle va
souffrir énormément
elle aussi mais jugé d'une mesure dans
sa capacité à arrêter la guerre s'est
fixé la barre bien trop pour pouvoir le
juger me sens bien criminel de guerre ou
pas veillé à poutine général 2002 lors
en tout cas les premières approches sont
très nettement charge à charge il en
laisse et
crois que
malheureusement dans toutes les guerres
les criminels de guerre sont parfois des
daims et deux camps est pas et pas
forcément par avoir une vision
manichéenne de la guerre malheureusement
l'histoire nous apprend que tout n'est
pas mais très clairement le plus grand
criminel de guerre c'est bien lui élise
le gal monsieur je pensais que ce très
important ce qu
il n'y a pas de dire son crime il ya
quelque chose d'assez étrange d'ailleurs
dans cette formulation et crimes de
guerre ça a été défini ce sont des des
massacres qui sont commission nécessité
sanitaire
oui mais la distinction entre civils et
militaires et du oui et aussi les crimes
en parle mais les crimes contre les
prisonniers les tortures paris
présiderait sont assimilables aux crimes
de guerre ce sont aussi des crimes élise
le gal peut-être vous aurez le mot de la
fin puisque crime criminel de guerre a
priori d'après diraient les indices le
dit mr poutine da par le fait que le
procureur de la cour pénale
internationale est ouvert une enquête
s'est déjà que ça démontre qu'il ya en
tout cas suffisamment d'éléments qui
laissent à penser que
et crimes de guerre sont en train d'être
commis en ukraine merci beaucoup élise
le gal d'avoir été avec ton direct de la
r11 hip hop l'ex général 2002 lors merci
beaucoup on y brandon merci à vous merci
elena et elena volochine et puis merci à
vous tous de nous avoir suivi vous
restez avec nous sans france à 4